So we saw that if we ask these three questions. Well
we needed three questions to be sure that we will find the
gold star, by opening box, but we don't need three questions.
If we are little smarter about our questions, we only need 2.
And the way to do it in 2 questions is to
ask for questions that gives us more information. So the problem with
asking the Is it in the green box? question first
Is that 3/4 of the time, the answer is no.
And if we're trying to use yes, no questions. Or we're trying to
use bits to get as much information as possible, what we want to do
is ask questions where the answer is equally likely to be yes as
it is to be no. We want a question where half the time the
answer is yes and half the time the answer is no. If the
question isn't like that, so if it's a question where it's no more
often than it's yes, well then we could guess the answer is no
and be right more than half the time. So we're not getting a full
bit of information in the result, because we had a good chance
of being right without getting that answer. So we want to figure out
questions where the answer is equally likely to be yes. As it
is to be no. So we could ask that as our first
question. So we're going to ask, is the gold star in either the
green or the purple box? So the answer is yes if it's
in one of those two boxes. The answer is no if it's
in either the blue or the red box. So, there are four boxes.
For two of the boxes the answer is going to be
yes, so half the time the answer is yes. So that
means, we're gaining one full bit of information. If the answer
is yes, we've learned that it's in either the green or
the pop-, purple box. If the answer is no, we've learned
that it's in either the blue or the red box. And
so if the answer is yes, well now we need to
ask one more question. To figure out which box it's in.
And that could be, is it in the green box?
And so, if we ask that question, if the answer is
yes, well then we know it's in the green box. If
the answer is no, then we know it's in the purple
box. We only needed two questions to get to the right
box. And that's the same, if the answer was no to
this. Well then we can ask is it in the blue
box? That's a yes no question. If the answer is yes,
well then we know it's in the blue box.
If the answer is no, then we know that it's
in the red box. So now, we can cover
all four possible boxes. We didn't need three questions like
we did when we asked, is it in the green box, is it in the purple box, is it
in the blue box? We might have needed three
questions to determine the box, here we only needed two.